mais j'ai vraiment pas cette place moi
je sais plus où ranger les affaires
qu'est ce que je vais faire de ce truc
je lui met là peut-être bon va le
téléphone le téléphone il serait par la
loi
le bocal oui mais alors le bocal de
caramel bah je vais me remettre la côte
est des autres bonbons et ben oui mais
je me retrouve avec ça mais ça va pas du
tout du tout du tout du tout ni j'ai ouï
casimir excuse moi j'ai vraiment pas le
temps de discuter je suis dans des
problèmes de rangement dont je ne sent
pas bon mais excuse moi de te déranger
comment faire
ah bonjour
je suis bien embêté
j'aimerais beaucoup que julie me chante
la chanson mais elle est très occupé et
je ne peux même pas lui parler
si si je l'obligent à m'écouter elle va
se mettre en colère elle ne chantera pas
d'un autre côté si je ne lui demande pas
bien ne changera jamais
c'est compliqué un
an mais j'ai j'ai une idée ouais
attendait
les enfants
il y a des garçons là oui
il ya des filles aussi
parfait bien
en soi oui
je voudrais que tu inventes un nouveau
jeu un nouveau jeu mais pourquoi j'en
connais des tas non non mais il faut
absolument que tu en invente à nouveau
c'est très important robot écoute
casimir je vais essayer un poteau 22e il
faut que ce soit un jeu facile un jeu
facile d'un ça c'est plus difficile
un jeu facile c'est difficile elle est
bien bonne julie oui à julie c'est
vraiment important oui regarde par là
qu'est ce que tu vois ben je défends mon
métier genre d'enfant qu'est ce que tu
veux dire des filles et des garçons
voilà très bien maintenant regarde moi
oui et alors non mais attends d'attendre
d'eux avec une chanson et un peu
d'imagination
je vous emmène dans le thriller au pays
du bonheur tranquille
puisque je comprends pas qu est ce que
tu veux et tu n'as pas compris
qui est en train de chanter ta chanson
voilà c'est ça bon maintenant regard de
françois françois qu'est-ce-qu'il 1 il
invente un nouveau jeu facile
ça y est j'ai compris pourquoi invente
un nouveau jeu facile je vois des filles
les garçons casimir chance à chanter tu
veux que je te chante ma chance et ça
ça fait vraiment plaisir poussette
j'aime bien le manque quand tu chantes
bon et ben d'accord au quasi me regarde
j'ai trouvé une place les battues voir
c'est mon idée qui va porter bonheur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de douceur
je voudrais faire
tri
m
j'y vois les garçons
oh
casimir show de sa chance
[Musique]
françois
nous venger
mais je l'aurais mieux pas si je vais à
fond
je leur ai mieux peu si j'étais un
enfant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le kiosque que les poupées
on y est
écoliers
couleurs série 6
m
[Musique]
à
papillons passe temps
pas si sûr
[Musique]
utile m
mais je m'en fais mieux ta si je fais
k
si j'étais un enfant
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout est fermé comme ça tu n'auras pas
trop de travail il te suffit de bien
veiller à ce que les enfants ne se fasse
pas mal et à faire attention parce que
personne ne s'approche trop du kiosque
ou des ballons de françois c'est compris
pour tu
écoutes ne manquent pas des facteurs lui
au moins c'est un homme très
consciencieux dans son travail je m'en
fiche parce que je ne sais même pas ce
que ça veut dire voyons casimir ce n'est
pas parce qu'on ne comprend pas quelque
chose qu'il faut s'en moquer au
contraire essayer d'apprendre ce que
l'on ne sait pas être très consciencieux
par exemple cela veut dire faire ce que
l'on fait très bien le plus sérieusement
du monde ah bon alors je te promets
d'être le gardien le plus consciencieux
du monde
situé le gardien le plus consciencieux
de l'île aux enfants ce sera déjà
formidable allez il faut que je te
quitte je vais rejoindre françois qui
doivent aider à repeindre les volets de
ma maison au revoir au revoir julie rey
soit tranquille il ne se passera rien
j'en suis sûr
oui
wahaha oh la la
quoi qu avez vous fait vous fait rire
parce que vous êtes ridicules mais alors
tellement ridicule aaa moi j'ai dit que
je ne vois vraiment pas pourquoi oh vous
est maigre mais alors quel moment
mais qu'est ce que vous faites ici vous
ne vous ne vais pas acheter la allait
très bien je pars
j'aurais voulu simplement vous poser une
question
bon mais alors une folle ne seriez-vous
pas le grand le célèbre casino las le
célèbre casimir oui c'est moi pourquoi
ai-je donc droit à une deuxième question
bon d'accord
n'aimeriez vous pas vivre dans une île
encore plus belle et devenir encore plus
célèbres robes je suis très bien ici je
ne veux pas aller dans une autre il ce
n'est pas ce que je voulais dire en
vérité moi robert et or ar je vous
propose de faire de l'île aux enfants
les la plus belle du monde il s'agit
d'une usine de gloubiboulga
surgelés avec distributeurs automatiques
en petits pots ou encore non aux du
gloubiboulga
glacé encorner et vous en aurez être
délicieux vous en aurez tant que vous
voudrez pas bon et alors où comptez-vous
construire cette cuisine et bien c'est
très simple avec des bulldozer on abat
les arbres de petit bois à battre le
petit bois qui hélas ne penser qu'à vous
gloubiboulga glace et ce sera délicieux
c'est vrai ça demande à certains
sacrifices
or on ne peut pas tout avoir très juste
monsieur quasiment oui d'ailleurs vous
savez au bout de quelques semaines vous
n'entendrez plus les bruits d'usiné les
bruits mais julien a horreur du bruit à
vous avez bien raison de penser à votre
ami mademoiselle julie je vais pouvoir
faire son bonheur elle aussi a elle
aussi et comment alors elle vit en
permanence dans son kiosque eh bien elle
pourra dormir tard le matin aller à la
plage toute la journée au faire de
grands voyages au pays comment
allez-vous faire alors eh bien je
remplace que son vieux kiosque branlant
par un magnifique kiosque en béton armé
de quatre étages avec 150 distributeurs
automatiques de boissons de jouets et de
cadeaux il suffit de mettre une pièce
pour avoir ce que l'on désigne mais
c'est formidable mais à des
distributeurs art alors je me verrais
par julie tous les jours ne soyez pas
égoïste ce son bonheur qui tombe c'est
vrai ouais et et françois alors un
françois je vais pouvoir faire son
bonheur aussi ah bon je suis très
content j'installerai une machine qui
vous fera du ballon par seconde et une
autre qui fera faire 25 e par jour aux
enfants du phare loi aura tout le temps
d'étudier tranquillement bon et alors
quand allez-vous pouvoir commencer
koussa et bien dès que vous aurez signé
ce petit papier pour me donner
l'autorisation de commencer comme moi je
peux décider de toutes ces choses là bas
oui mais oui je viens de vérifier dans
le livre de l'île aux enfants et j'ai
découvert une vieille loi que tout le
monde avait oublié et qui dit que le
dernier descendant de casimir premier
roi de casimir us peut prendre toutes
les décisions qui lui semblent bonnes
pour l'île aux enfants de n'est signé
merci et que tournez vous et et baissez
vous que je puisse a signé sur votre dos
volontiers pour une signature hausse
historique mais monsieur retors que
veulent dire ces phrases écrit en tout
petit je n'arrive même pas à aller lire
le ce n'est rien ce sont des formules
obligatoire sans importance signé à
attraper lumbago si ce sont des formules
sans importance est différent
monsieur rathor qu'y a t'il encore à il
n'ya plus d'encre dans votre stylo ce
type pour les mauvais pain et non je
n'en ai pas et il est le casque de julie
est fermé aux
voilà monsieur duchesneau s'est très
bien vous savez il ya toujours un stylo
sur lui que monsieur devons les sauver
écoutez écoutez je ne peux pas rester
signé ce petit papier ce soir chez vous
je passerai chercher demain matin et non
par la personne banques mais ligue et
pas à personne oui c'est une surprise
mais monsieur retour au revoir à demain
aux
nouvelles normes en casimir ah oui
enfin non
pour écoutez je ne devrais pas vous en
parler parce que c'est une surprise mais
je vais signer un contrat qui va rendre
tous les habitants de l'île heureux bon
mais c'est passionnant cette voie là où
lé hula o laulala quelle horreur mais
c'est affreux mais que se passe-t-il mon
bon du snav non enfin kazim tu allais
faire notre malheur à nous tous mais non
votre bonheur as tu seulement lui ces
quelques lignes écrites en tout petit
lettre la la non non ça monsieur retour
m'a dit que c'était des petites formules
sans important oui eh bien écoutez
formule sans importance
après la signature de ce contrat
françois julie le facteur monsieur du
snow dont casimir devront quitter l'île
aux enfants pour toujours quoi mais
c'est vraiment ce qui est écrit ya
exactement
mais alors ce monsieur ressources c'est
un bandit disons que c'est un homme
d'affaires pas très honnête taureau mais
alors qu'est ce que je vais faire quand
il va revenir demain et bien écoutez à
venir nous allons être là tous les deux
à l'attendre merci monsieur disent non
merci il va voir ce retour au il va voir